the walking dead boasts one of the
biggest
casts on tv as a result it's enjoyed a
whole lot of unique cameos
so many in fact that you might not have
noticed most of them
these are the most surprising
interesting
and just plain strange cameos on the
walking dead
heinz ward was among the nfl's most
athletic
dazzling and accomplished wide receivers
in the late 1990s and 2000s
in his 14 season career spent entirely
with the pittsburgh steelers
he managed 1 000 successful receptions
placing him high on the all-time list
which led to four pro bowl selections
and two super bowl rings
ward was drafted out of the university
of georgia where one of his teammates on
the gridiron was running back irony
singleton who pursued
acting upon graduation singleton found
success
in hollywood landing roles in movies
like remember the titans
the blind side and the longest yard and
eventually on the first three seasons of
the walking dead in which he portrayed
zombie apocalypse survivor
theodore douglas aka t-dog in 2012
ward utilized his connection to
singleton to land a small role on the
walking dead as well
which was then shooting in his home
state of georgia when the show's
location moved to a semi-abandoned
prison
ward got to play one of the zombies who
pounced on the main survivor characters
ward spent two hours in makeup to be
transformed into a walker
where an artist painted his old jersey
number 86 onto the back of his head
even as a stumbling zombie we wouldn't
want to go up against him
before the walking dead hit amc in 2010
and produced some
of the best viewership numbers in cable
tv history
zombie entertainment was primarily seen
as niche fair
enjoyed by only a relatively small
segment of the population
sure everyone knew what zombies were but
only dedicated fans could offer opinions
on
night of the living dead or discuss the
finer points of reanimator
zombies were in other words for nerds
but then those much-maligned individuals
enjoyed a big
moment in the early 2010s comedian chris
hardwick an avowed nerd had just
launched his popular nerdist podcast
the first brick in a media empire that
caters to
well unabashed nerds like himself
when the walking dead returned for its
highly anticipated second season in 2011
new episodes were followed by a new
series talking dead
on talking dead cast and crew from the
walking dead and special celebrity
guests
gathered to talk about the episode that
just aired the whole endeavor is hosted
by the always enthusiastic and proudly
nerdy hardwick
holy sh those two shows
collided and hardwick earned himself a
major thrill
when in 2019 the nerdist founder made a
brief
hard to spot appearance on the walking
dead near the end of the episode
scars a walker tries to attack judith
that zombie is none other than hardwick
who achieved in that moment
the peak of zombie nerfdam
anthrax's scott ian is one of a rare
breed
the most famous member of a band even
though he isn't the lead singer
since the 1980s ian has played guitar in
the legendary thrash metal group and has
perpetually
overshadowed the group's various singers
he sports a memorable look what with his
shaved head and long pointy wizard beard
ian is also a big fan of horror media
and once
hosted a web series called blood works
where he explored how gore effects are
made
it's 5 15 or something in the morning
here in atlanta and
we're on the set of walking dead all
these unique qualities
along with his friendship with walking
dead special effects makeup designer
greg nicotero
helped land ian a gig on cable's top
zombie show
in 2011 ian was rendered unrecognizable
by a thick slathering of gore and makeup
effects in his appearance as a walker on
a webisode of the walking dead
he returned to the franchise in the 2015
episode remember
his anonymous zombie hides under a trash
heap and reaches out
to grab the leg of an unsuspecting rick
grimes
but is quickly stopped when the sheriff
allows his son carl
to shove a metal pole through the undead
ian's head
instantly dispatching him what a gory
way to go but then again we're not sure
this horror hound would be happy with
anything less whitware has done voice
work for the star wars universe
held the major role of davis bloom for a
season of the superman centric series
smallville
played vampire aiden weight on four
seasons of being human
and portrayed mr hyde of horror legend
on once upon a time
nearly a decade into his bustling career
as an actor in both film and tv
woodward took a role on the first
episode of the walking dead one
with no lines and scant screen time the
part
tank soldier a zombified ex-military man
that rick grimes has to kill in atlanta
woodward was supposed to return to the
show later on as show runner frank
darabont wanted to produce some prequel
episodes about the fall of atlanta to
zombies as originally planned whitmer
would have reportedly had a more robust
role playing that soldier before his
zombification but
unfortunately those episodes never came
to pass
most television viewers and film goers
might not know
mcganey by name but they certainly
recognize his face
the prolific character actor has
appeared in nearly 200
projects usually in small but pivotal
roles and typically as a villain
ganey plays angry guys corrupt authority
figures
violent criminals and like his
impressive resume includes roles like
big john brittle and django unchained
tom friendly on lost and papa poutine on
riverdale
if a character played by ganey shows up
it generally means
very bad news for the film or tv series
protagonist
ganey told the junction with a face like
this there aren't a lot of lawyers or
priestworlds coming my way
it's true gainey's mug is a craggy
marvel that was
made to loom menacingly out of the
shadows
audiences are likely to be most familiar
with gainey for his work as swamp thing
in conair or perhaps beau crowder
unjustified but
probably not at all from his time on the
walking dead
he appeared just once on the walking
dead in the 2014 episode slab town
his recognizable face heavily obscured
by thick makeup
so he could amble around as an anonymous
zombie
in 2002 keisha castle hughes enjoyed
what is probably the best response an
actor can get for their debut
performance
at just 12 years old the australian-born
actress starred in the highly acclaimed
new zealand-produced film
whale writer for which she earned an
academy award nomination for best
actress
she was at the time the youngest person
to ever be recognized in that category
she then reemerged in 2015 as the fierce
dornish warrior obara sand on game of
thrones
just before she joined the cast of that
megawatt
hbo series castle hughes booked a spot
on the walking dead in the 2014 episode
slabtown she portrayed joan
a zombie outbreak survivor held prisoner
by gorman
bitten by a walker during an escape
attempt she endures
a gruelling arm amputation but
ultimately
takes her own life by opening her
stitches and allowing herself to bleed
out
joan then reanimates as a zombie and is
killed by dawn lerner
though the walking dead's ratings
figures had fallen off from the
stratospheric levels the show once
reached at its peak
it still remained one of the most
popular and high profile shows on cable
tv by the time
2019 rolled around all throughout the
series run
it's been a lucrative gig for actors
landing a role on the show can serve as
marvelous exposure for any actor even
one who has already established
themselves on other well-known
television series
and even if you're just there for a
one-off role to show up
zombie out and get shot that's very much
the case for routina wesley
who first found fame as tara thornton on
hbo's lauded vampire saga true blood
after her time on that show ended in
2014 wesley enjoyed a
long arc on nbc's hannibal as reba
mclean
as well as a couple of guest spots on
the cw's flagship dc superhero series
arrow in 2016 she began starring as nova
board alone on the celebrated oprah
winfrey network family drama
queen sugar one truth emerges from
wesley's filmography
she's busy flexible and just as
comfortable portraying the nuances of
bereavement as she is hanging out with
vampires
despite her packed schedule wesley found
time to appear on
a single episode of the walking dead in
2019.
in scars wesley portrayed jocelyn or
joss a cruel and controlling leader of a
cult-like collective of children
michonne her old friend from before the
end of the world arrived
is forced to end her wicked ways
in addition to the walking dead comics
series writer robert kirkman
and the tv series developer frank
darabont the one person who has had the
biggest
behind behind-the-scenes impact on the
long-running zombie show is greg
nicotero
he's directed more than 30 episodes
served as various types of producer
and heads up the show's special effects
makeup department
which means he's responsible for turning
groups of
actors into monstrously flesh dripping
zombie hordes
to say he's an integral part of the show
is
a massive understatement every now and
then nicotero even gets in on the fun
taking a spin in the zombification chair
himself between
2010 and 2016 nicotero appeared in five
episodes each time as an undead walker
his walking dead colleagues tend to
grant him some of the most
plum zombie assignments available in one
appearance
set in the town of woodbury for example
he was tasked with lunging at andrea who
stops him with a pistol blast to the
head
this is my friend this is greg nicotero
a tv adaptation of the walking dead
might look and feel
completely different if not for the work
of charlie adler
in 2004 adler joined the creative staff
of the comic series upon which the show
is based as a penciller
from there on he helped bring the
stories of robert kirkman and his other
collaborators to life
until its final issue hit stands in
2019.
when you think of the walking dead comic
what you picture is adler's work
his vision of the apocalypse full of
dark inky shadows and weathered faces
is a terrifying triumph of comics art to
say
nothing of the fact that it formed the
foundation of what became
one of the most popular shows on tv
appropriately enough
adler got to be part of the tv world he
helped to realize
during production of the show's first
season in the summer of 2010
he reported to the set of the walking
dead to spend three days filming a cameo
appearance as a walker
as he later recounted in an interview
with comicbookmovie.com
it was a thrilling experience as he
recalled
three days of seeing my creations come
to life i felt very privileged
adler can be seen amongst the horde of
walkers that attacks a very confused
sheriff rick grimes in atlanta in days
gone by
the very first episode of the walking
dead
after building up a reputation as a
versatile actor and
something of a muse for filmmaker tim
burton in quirky classics
like ed wood edward scissorhands and
sleepy hollow johnny depp became one of
the biggest movie stars
in the world in the 21st century he
starred as captain jack sparrow in
five enormously successful pirates of
the caribbean movies
as the mad hatter in two alice in
wonderland adventures
and is gellert grindelwald in the harry
potter prequel fantastic beasts
the crimes of grindelwald in 2016 depp
even made time for a brief
guest star appearance on an episode of
the walking dead or
at least part of him did and apparently
without his knowledge
or active participation in the episode
not tomorrow yet a decapitated human
head makes an appearance that bears
a strong resemblance to depth according
to makeup and effects wizard and
not tomorrow yet director greg nicotero
that's because the head is
in fact johnny depp's head nicotero told
entertainment weekly i think we had
sculpted an
emaciated version of a dummy head for
something and we used
johnny depp's hat as a basis just for a
clay sculpt
that's certainly one way of making an
appearance
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you